[Music]
one comedian plus one joint plus
research equals stoned sides - fair
enough stones I'm here about the science
digestion and they explain what's
happening right now so I'm truly that's
called mastication which sounds like
masturbation it's but maybe like your
body's it doesn't matter anyway so
saliva no super important because it has
this enzyme that breaks down starch
that's a lot like bread chips so I
probably have because I need a lot of
surgery stuff the starch wait no the
enzymes called salivary amylase oh and
then there's like also Bugis you guess
like coats everything while it's going
down cuz like foods sure lots of future
we're like just like matches just like
it going down even a steak it's like you
never really enough time it's just hard
in general but chips are pointy cutting
myself so that starts going down my
esophagus it's like so the bolus happens
and that's it's dropped down into the
stomach honestly a lot of people think
is a lot lower than it is it's pretty
high because there's so much other and
weirdos like I don't like that spirited
testified oh and then things get really
weird
the stomach has all this like
hydrochloric acid it starts doing this
like thing so peristalsis that's okay
it's like do the snake like in your body
pushing it like doing you like look you
see how might exercise when you're like
slipping class in high school
night over each other in the ocean and
everyone like pushes the water think you
have to like swim through it and
hopefully you get to the end it's like
that but in your stomach with the food
that's where they try to jab me I will
Jam you up so hard I will Jam you from
morning until night no one else though
that's an exercise now we are trying to
move it to the small Testament so then
so they're using terror sites and
they're covered in little like
microscopic like this little like villi
which I think should be and then they
they're covered in little microscopic
like even smaller bill on and they're
like fingers it's like expert baby
there's like figures on it's turning the
food it's great little like bubbles and
those bubbles like bread like to give
you nutrients like how you're able to
like survive yeah somebody goes in the
morning test time basically stays in
there for a really long time it could be
like six hours but it can be 50 hours
1150 hours from city why let go I'll
never let go
right so you know you're walking around
the woods with a feeling so so now it's
like this is like crazy
it stores this okay okay like ferments
and it turns into this like nasty that's
it leave your body because there's no
use for it anymore like I smell like
past so it goes through there through
like we know where you know where it
comes from it comes out with the anus
that's the whole process it goes all the
way from to like Riley Greene its but
there's so much has happened inside your
body's just like ah really
anyway McDonald's yeah that's pretty
much it that's how digestion works right
thank you so much for watching our
second episode of stone science we
really hope that you liked it and let us
know what are some other scientific
concepts you want a stoned comedian to
explain and it might be next if you want
to watch the first episode we'll put it
over here otherwise you can subscribe
and we will see you next time for some
more science peace